hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute ein spiel das wir spielen happy
ich habe kommentare gelesen dass es sich
gewünscht wurde
ja wir klicken einfach mal auf play und
gibt sie irgendwelche neuen sachen dies
[Musik]
ist fast so viel wie ich bei akinator
der text die fibel ide and des
apocalypse ich muss erstmal wieder
wissen wie die bosse levels gemacht ein
mieter hatte die vierte liga und potent
ist so gern ich bin zu langsam für die
dialoge so hab ich das spiel mal
gespielt der axt auf mich geworfen it's
getting late
schnell hoch und jetzt hier war und mein
bein gerade hier die hülle runter und
die hier über das wasser und vielleicht
nicht einmal geräusche machen wenn ich
mich anstrenge auch mein gott was ist
denn das hier schon wieder kann es in
diesem level nicht einmal etwas geben
wurde nicht ich muss leider helfen
diesem licht der oa gleitet was soll das
leiter ist wohl dieses licht nämlich
irgendwie helfen soll und das ist doch
nicht wahr wie dass diese spieler so
gewalttätig ich habe getötet
ich bin geil ich bin hässlich
[Musik]
das level was wir jetzt spielen ist ein
spiel von einem user kreiert und dafür
nehmen wir kommen wir mal den alten mann
ihm mit seinem traktor ich starte das
level und hänge direkt danach ab und das
macht voll spaß gerade okay
ich fahre immer weiter voran und es ist
eigentlich auch dass ich
ich muss mich jetzt gerade durch melonen
durch hatten damit ich jetzt jeden
moment tatsächlich auch dass sie auch
dann mal
[Musik]
da
ihr seht das ja auch mein ellbogen will
ihr das tool das das spiel so brutal ist
oder danke für eure antworten hängen
jetzt übrigens ein anderer politiker ich
halte es habe ich mir noch mit einem
bagger an dem mikrofon gestoßen da
hinten anderer pony weil ja kauft die
sachen einfach die sind ab dem ersten
zwölfter im shop also kaufte das duca
macht so gute wer bei diesem level nehme
ich jetzt mal diesen etwas dickeren
typen mit seinem helikopter und ich
hoffe dass wirklich dieses level jetzt
mal endlich etwas
etwas ist was nicht so gewalttätig ist
wie die anderen level bisher
ich habe mich geirrt kommen die kammern
wir müssen einfach nur
[Musik]
helikopter
bei bier ich will nicht dass nicht immer
schlechter wird arbeitet definitiv immer
brutaler
wie nennt man es wenn man einen richtig
guten freund etwas geld gibt dann hat er
einen brutalen brutaler brno wegen
bruder und thaler wegen totaler geld
brutale dieses level sollte anscheinend
nicht so brutal sein denn jubelt die
treter dein lob ließ er kommt kannst du
nicht vielleicht einfach warten wenn du
auf mich
na
ich tue mir das nicht mehr an das
komplette spiel ist voll mit gewalt
sobald nicht ganz witzig wenn euch das
video gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen denn davon gibt es
zu wenig auf der welt und wir brauchen
auch der wert wirklich viel mehr
bewertungen